ready kick ass take names let's do it
hopefully just my natural charm will win
you over
yeah you still need my approval backlog
you know got so much self higher exact
nation I'm Greg Alba hi I'm Paula Deming
paula Deming is here if you guys are
fans of the fan theory TV YouTube
channel you will have noticed that
Paulo's they're covering Doctor Who
right now we know that this subscriber
base love some Doctor Who and constantly
gives me crap for not watching the show
oh my gosh it's so good if you know
watched it it's exactly my night yeah I
have not I'm watching it for the first
time and I love it so far but aren't you
on the new season no we started with
number nine Christopher Eccleston oh
that means nothing to me that's where
you got to go and start watching it and
also Paula does a lot of game streaming
with stream on Twitch if you're into
Let's Plays of narrative games or weird
indie stuff that's what I like oh yeah
hey Paula before we were filming you
said that you had recently started a
show called Jane the virgin I did I just
heard I was on an airplane I was like
okay I'll watch this and I watched the
first three episodes of Jane the virgin
and I loved it and I'm really sad but I
didn't start watching it sooner I've
seen the first episode yeah there was
another show out I forget which one but
Gina Rodriguez is starring in this new
movie called Miss Bala I have no idea
what this about coincidence I think not
I have no idea what this is about but
that's our little segue I've never heard
of it so we're very fresh let's find out
what it's going on here uno dos tres
whoa oh she's badass in there yeah I'm
not giving up my family so happy that
you're here after my parents died and I
didn't really think I was gonna be able
to come back to Tijuana but you always
made me feel like family you are my
family
just like taken but with sisters oh yeah
[Music]
I'll kill you both what favor could she
possibly
you just killed some people yeah oh she
go take my badge
the DEA stay calm unless you help us
[Music]
who's coming to save you whether or not
you service ID entirely up to you what
everybody is using her for something
what everything oh she's a natural
better do what you need to do until you
know there's a mole in his operation
I am already stressed out from the
trailer
the bullet that's where I that's where
I'm going Valentine's Day that's the
romantic movie I'm going to I have let's
hear about this it's perfect like
they're all over the place
one I said this but everyone wants her
for something she's in this tough spot
of like the bad guys want to manipulate
her for something then the good guys
want to manipulate her to be a bad guy
or a good guy we don't know and I'm
already stressed out by the idea of that
yeah well it seems like a really
convoluted plot to me yeah like it
starts off where she's just a girl who's
with her sister and our brand-new she's
like family then they're at a club then
the club gets shot up and then she wants
to go find her I was kind of confused
and then why did they think they could
use her to do things like she which then
leads to the feds going you're gonna be
our rat which is now leading to her
becoming a badass and this gang life
she's like she couldn't be doing whoa
wait a minute this is getting like way
out of proportion
the trailer didn't tell us that
everyone's like oh she's actually
already in international someone be like
that girl yeah she's gonna do some stuff
I'm good and I'm bad aim so don't don't
come kidnap well it seems like she
starts off as normal girl who evolves
into badass but I couldn't tell her cuz
there was that moment where the bad guy
she's about to die but she chooses to
save him and then from what the trailer
was telling me she's doing that because
you know this is what she's been hired
to do so you need to probably you know
get more information because the goal is
to put him behind bars I'm wondering
though is she gonna have that thing
where she has an internal conflict about
which side am I on
it seems like the story's just pulling
this one character in so many different
directions so I feel like I might walk
away with this movie going that that
plot was very much overdone but I will
say Gina Rodriguez looks like she's
gonna kill it in this movie
yeah if nothing else I'd be excited to
just watch her be a badass
yes exactly are some guns punch some
dudes I'm here for that because often
when actresses are put in this position
to become like sexy badass action hero
it's usually quite cheesy and the weird
thing about this trailer is even though
there's so much going on one thing I
thought this trailer would eventually
get to and other than the end when she's
like in the hot sexy red dress it just
seems so out of place with everything I
saw from her character in this trailer
other than that one moment most of the
Civic community eat is cheesy to me
which actually made me happy because
nine times out of ten this would just be
a very corny piece of material I
wondered to of they're gonna do this
whole exploration of like well who are
the guys who are the bad guys yeah we
think are bad guys at first actually the
good guys like government guys the bad
guys and like is that a flip that's
gonna happen how would their gang guys
be the good guy there are freedom
fighters there humanitarian of the
cartel okay but like Maid Marion is
kidnapped by over they in Colombia I'm
looking at the trailer like you were
pointing out there's this image where it
looks like the sister who's kidnapped is
maybe therms likes to have a sex
trafficking like almost like mugshot fee
yeah I mean they're crying but I don't
think it was a mugshot it feels like I'm
gonna put this photo of you on the
internet and tell you to someone
yeah it kind of does have that vibe
which would make this more like take and
then like you pointed out
yeah that's exactly it's not clear I
mean they said family and the taglines
family but it seemed like they could be
best friends you view themselves as
beside the point this is very important
character her obviously she's trying to
savor right that means actually looks a
lot better
Anthony Mackey's in it playing someone
that's awesome Pilates working outside
of these Avengers movies yeah do you
know Rodriguez you look like a badass
you ain't no virgin anymore that doesn't
make sense
that's a weird statement to make she's
not so innocent as perhaps subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell but you notify what videos are up
make sure to check out miss Paula yeah
check out that fan Theory TV 4 we watch
you if you're in the Doctor Who and find
me on Twitch if you like Let's Plays
it's a good time and social media stuff
as well you got to follow everywhere
yeah America
side or right side I believe that's the
right side I asked because I have a
hearing thing so I need to really yeah
oh do you yeah I'm hearing him say I
didn't deaf and one here so if it's in
stereo I won't hear anything on the left
channel all right this is neither here
nor there but I'm just gonna tell you
this story real quick sure um so in high
school band there is a kid who sat next
to me the whole time all year and then
it be one day I was like oh wait are you
saying something to me it was like yeah
I was like oh I can't hear in this ear
so just say it again and he was like all
the whole year long I thought you were
just ignoring me oh you have no idea I'm
sure that happens a lot in your life I'm
sorry